save yourself before you try to save the
world the best way to help the poor is
not to become one of them get your money
right son
worry about the money after you practice
marshal you develop this natural self
confidence not cockiness but you develop
this natural self-confidence save
yourself before you try to save the
world the best way to help the poor is
not to become one of them it is your
duty it is your obligation it is your
responsibility to maximize your profits
as an entrepreneur think about it let me
give an analogy it's like if you want to
give blood how many beg to blood you can
give before you pass out and die that's
that's linear thinking that's an
employee mentality you want to give
blood bill Hospital
that's entrepreneurial mindset that's
entrepreneur mindset now some people
might say but then money is not that
important
right
Oh
[Applause]
then you know money doesn't buy a
happiness I'll talk to my wife
you don't think money
yeah if you talked to her she would say
Eevee though you'll think money can buy
happiness you don't know where to shop
okay and money here's the thing money
it's not supposed to buy you happiness
money is supposed to give you two things
how many things two things first money
gives you comfort makes your life a
little easier
and second thing is money allows you to
do to extend the goods that you do
beyond your physical presence to only
two things when pson wanting here i am
my name is not the important money
doesn't buy happiness very often it's a
stupid statement first of all but second
thing is usually it's a defensive
statement it's usually people would say
that you either don't you don't have any
oh they don't they don't know how to get
some guarantee so from now on you can be
a psychic you hear people our money is
not that important money doesn't buy
happiness oh my goodness let me think
let me think
you're broke and they would be like how
do you know
if I could go back to my 20 year old
self when I would tell my 20 year old
self is one thing get your money right
son
worry about the money and now I know a
lot of people think that this is not the
thing people should be focused on
however on this planet if you don't get
your money right you're gonna be worried
all the debt all the time you can't take
care of your parents you can't take care
of yourself you can't take care of your
rent you can't live in a nice place you
can't take care of your car get your
money right okay what should you be
spending your money on why do wealthy
people use money not spend money why do
wealthy people buy businesses they don't
buy homes why to wealthy people use debt
to grow their business they don't use
debt to consume products and services
why do wealthy people not invest in 401
K since EPS and retirement accounts they
don't even worry about that they worry
about getting their money so freaking
right but they can go wherever they want
day or night hi this is Dan Locke if
you're a fan of Evans work if you want
to know exactly how the model my success
I want to invite you to join me for a
special online training all you have to
do is click on a link below you can join
me for absolutely no charge so click a
link below and I will see you in class
getting rich is not an act it is a habit
so it is staying poor it's also not an
act it's nothing just happens to you it
is a habit